I hinted earlier in the lesson about architectural description languages. These
are, as it sounds, notations for describing architectures. They provide an extra
modicum of formality and precision, that goes beyond just having a diagram.
Moreover, by having that extra precision, it then enables some tool support. For
example, building to diagram the tool. Diagram a solution in such a way,
that the diagramming tool can check for whether you've done things well.
Analyzers, okay, for determining the structural properties and
behavioral properties of your system. And even simulators.
I've listed here some of the popular architectural description languages.
The one that we'll be looking at a little bit later is called Acme.